>>Susan: Making books is a very
valuable tool to help children
to really gain a good understanding of
what any subject matter might be about.
They're invested in it, and
they really become experts
on in the content of the books.
>>John: The accordion fold
does a zig-zagging paper fold.
>>John: The bookmaking came
about through an idea of
starting sketch books.
And then the excitement over bookmaking
culminated into teachers saying, "Well,
you know, it'd be nice if we could get
the curriculum into these books, too."
>>Susan: Each child will be producing an
actual book that they will get to keep
and the teachers in the grade level
chose what the topic would be,
and what style of book.
>>John: After we make the books here
in the art room, they take them back
to the classroom to integrate the
content based on whatever their unit is
that they're currently studying.
>>Susan: I used to teach idioms
by reading books to children
that had idioms in them, and
worksheet-type activities.
The bookmaking took it
to a whole new level,
where the kids really took ownership.
>>Katie: We're doing
like idiom pop-up books.
It's kind of like an expression,
like you don't mean it literally.
>>Isaiah: "Don't put all
your eggs in one basket,"
means "Don't put all your
resources in one possibility."
>>Ava: "Feeling under the weather,"
means you're feeling sick or ill.
>>Gwennie: It's just really fun to
draw the idioms, because you don't get
to draw things like that every day.
>>Victor: You can use your
imagination really, like right now,
I'm doing "Elvis left
the building," I think.
It means like, "The show
is over," and stuff.
>>Robby: "Barking up the wrong tree,"
you think you're doing
something right, but you're not.
>>Gwennie: "To steal someone's
thunder" means to take credit
for something someone else did.
>>Susan: They're not only learning about
the idioms in their own pop-up books,
they're learning about
the meanings of the idioms
that their classmates are
putting into their books as well.
So it's a great process of
discovery, and creating.
>>John: They've spent this time putting
a lot of effort into the quality
of their work, how they're using
materials, thinking with their hands.
So these books are really
special to them.
Now this knowledge that they're learning
has a really magical place to go.
>>Gretchen: For the fifth grader,
bookmaking project is focusing
on geography, and so we came up with
the idea to do an accordion book
with pockets so that we
could house doodle maps,
which we thought were really
cool in terms of being able
to share information, but
also incorporate in drawing.
>>Gretchen: Who remembers
one of the themes?
Mia?
>>Mia: Place, it's like how
you recognize a certain area.
You might recognize Keene as cold,
but beautiful leaves in the autumn.
>>Gretchen: So our next step is
to think about these five themes
and how they're represented in the
different regions of the United States.
>>Gretchen: They definitely
do a lot of research,
and then they're deciding
how they incorporate
that information in and represent it.
>>Kyah: When we draw it out, we
have to look up what movement
and region, and all that means.
And then we have to draw
a picture relating
to the three sentences we
wrote for the definition.
I didn't really know
the States very well,
and then once we started doing this, I
started knowing crops, and the climate,
and what animals are there.
I learned a lot more.
>>Student: This is really
coming together!
>>Gretchen: Our goal is
for them to really get
to know the country that they live in.
So instead of me saying, "Oh,
here's a map of the 50 States,
and we'll study it, and
we'll take a test about it,"
this is a lot more hands-on, and the
learning just seems more real for them.
>>Calvin: I'm a really good drawer, so
I wouldn't really like doing a report.
>>Maverick: I used to feel like
geography was stupid, dumb, horrible.
>>Kyah: This is Gary.
>>Maverick: But now I actually
think it's really cool.
>>John: If we can actually create
something that's relevant to us,
we take that knowledge deeper into us.
I think it just helps us to learn.
>>Susan: Each classroom
has a variety of learners,
and students who need the hands-on
experience, and those who tend
to be more creative, have really
benefited from the bookmaking process.
>>John: Those materials
that you're manipulating
to create something can have worth
outside of just a pretty picture.
It has staying power.